[Aplausos]
olá boa tarde digital é no sistema no
mês de setembro passado é de setembro é
eu resolvi descer o odor vinha para o
douro vinhateiro é parte da china no
mercado do ouro 2009 serão num barco a
remos é assim do mapa do danton
forrester
hoje o rio douro esta é esse é um lago
efeito muito bonito é e muita gente
procura fazer apresentou outro que está
na moda o turismo é imensa gente se vê
lo pelos mortos é grande a desvantagem
só ganhou festinha sair e repassa hoje
esse é o sonho de qualquer maneira
observaremos pode ser um bom pai cantor
e papa aos tá toda essa forma e eu quis
descer por uma carga emocional muito
maior de trabalhar e o patrulhamento e
continua a trabalhar fragmentar em
ternos né
à margem do douro e venda do dólar era
de frente do caso do que é hoje
o ponto de cultura desta forma vamos
fazer um vinho e eu tive a sorte do jogo
eu na minha maneira de ver que quando
como saída é como sair nos finais dos
anos 80 do século passado é não havia
grandes adegas os novos não ficavam um
teso navega tenha pintado é e da empresa
que trabalhava numa empresa inglesa
tinha 50 dólares que nós
visitávamos traz outra divina e isso vai
usar distribuídos praticamente pronta
por tardia
portanto desde um frio até barca d'alva
e cruzava um rio na régua nuno pinheiro
usava o recurso observou que essa nova
loira é a última quinta que acreditava
era em frente para a cinta nove
lançamentos do bric foi o primeiro tempo
é no tempo de salazar e que eu fui
campeã foi a última pessoa ea sua ea sua
tripulação é por acaso num barco da
empresa onde trabalhava aconteceu rio é
da construção da barragem é
o oovoo o fato am é o fim a descer foi
há dois anos atrás em que o final nos
arquivos da empresa estava muito sombrio
onu e conhecendo já que celso roth
vazamento vai o mapa do borel mas tive a
ver com mais pormenor é o que eu quero é
extraordinário do rio branco foi essa
ter feito este mapa é editado em 1948
tentou é o primeiro atentado do século
19 mas com promove um estádio enorme e
começou a ver eu toda essa detalhe
muitas quintas que eu conhecia
no caso eu tinha visitava determinadas
regiões e então dentro do cruzeiro do
oeste
neste mapa coisas extraordinárias eu
tinha e foi feliz aqui na apresentação
elmer coutos este vez pontos navegação
dizer que havia 210 pontos desde a dor
internacional até a foto do e que era
difícil navegação e porque eu queria
muito aquele que o rio fosse navegável
desta forma até os países que aqui uma
dizendo a uma caixa é um dos pontos nos
quais constam marcado nos carros de
baixo e há um mapa com o próprio rio em
que eu marque as distâncias e as
distâncias entre determinados pontos da
margem esquerda e vai marcar é o tempo
que o bateu a cabeça faziam dois pontos
e fazer a comparação na altura que a
torcida e numa dessas 62 pontos com as
duas horas a fazer é isso que moravam 30
minutos nos faziam na margem esquerda
tenho é velocidade que fazia no inverno
e na margem eta é o sinal que eu fazia
no no brasil para verem a velocidade que
o o que o filho tinha que ser a força do
time para alcançar essa sociedade daí
problema agora já o barco e o barco ela
joão barco que meu pai é é nava amava e
com a minha mãe com as minhas tias é
estamos a falar nos anos 20 e 30 do do
século passado que era um barco que eu
ainda não consegui por tiro ou
exatamente o nome em inglês mas em
português é um piquenique porque eu sei
eu subi um rio até agora ainda 20 e
acaba fazendo um piquenique
talvez a lançar o valor que um barco em
matéria eu tenho tem 16 metros em maio
um metro e com largo e foi desencantar
ao normal
o porto é não achei que é aparentemente
nesta fotografia aparece aparece muito
bonito também é em muito bom estado e
foi assim que iniciar isso vai água avaí
em nono e noel água não entra só hoje
tanto o ano dentro do armazém
o resultado é que o vasco estava em
muito mau estado
a caminhada é estava feita e e aqui e
espero que foi desenhado um dos meus
vizinhos que também acompanhou parte da
data da viagem e que mostra é a nossa
tripulação à frente o chamado proa é a
frente o flu volta a preocupar com o
ritmo do barco e o time mineiro vai
atrás do time na ativa além de vitória
intervalo tinha função é ter marcando os
pontos do que o do outro parando
floresta ii perante tamanho algumas
fotografias que ficou marcado para a
província 4 de setembro lançar está todo
barca d'alva porque eu queria chegar no
dia 10 de setembro que é bom que é que
foi sábado era precisamente para época
eram o que é oportunidade e eu queria
deixar uma marca uma a minha minha tia
numa placa tinha ido a essa é é o que eu
tinha feito a viagem quando tatu viagem
foi feito foi o novo nome mas ela está
no paraguai para a barca d'alva
ficamos lá nessa noite no domingo quando
nós estávamos na fofa e não tínhamos o
barco pra fazer pra notar o início é
essa viagem é muito bonita
parece um caso do filme
exatamente que se isso aconteceu é e
nessa altura fica no santos até por
pressão é o meu genro esteve fazer a
outros já daniel carvalho com alguma
preocupação
ainda na parte técnica como barco iria
funcionar e uma peça fundamental é o meu
filho vasco é meu filho mais novo é que
é o grande responsável por eu estar aqui
hoje tênis neste palco foi um evento
importante mas também o peso
o peso tem oque é um fim é o dobro do
meu tamanho é e maura entra no barco é a
campanha o perito vai que é uma tarefa
que é de cláudia eu fui lá com os três
pontos aqui mas a médio direito
o barco são ter água e nunca mais
responder agora estou aqui é que o
pássaro que eu queria dar passou a ser
de fato uma grande aventura
nós já estava farto e começamos eram 99
pontos com 100 mil tanto para cavar uma
coisa né
os passageiros de mais bonito e mais
emocionante para mim por ter vivido
tanto deve ter conseguido é pra já
começar é grande viagem
e aqui está no shopping barca d'alva e
vamos com tudo e vamos entrar numa zona
é que salva uma extensão da ana almeida
está em ruínas em que é ter a força foto
com a 9 anos tinha nenhuma 9 a quinta a
única vinha e que é preciso no mapa do
brasil com essa equipe do estúdio uma
noite nada
como já não passa não há estradas na
margem esquerda negócio diretor do do
rio foi uma terra ultimamente muito
tocado a partir dos 79 é que por trás da
motoca lavra que temos a quinta da leda
os outros produtores antes de outras
grandes marcas começam a aparecer
é o caso do órgão franco é cabreira do
do prato na hora em que ela está tão
ligado ao falava esta casa caso do rio
nós temos a total chegará a foto do
corpo são a zona é
o fato havia mais terra disponível mas
não só é um espacinho agora grande
visibilidade e de grande qualidade e
adilza cálculos das empresas
o portuguesinho do workshop são a todas
instaladas para nos propomos ar na nano
fora do dodô sabor é e continuamos a
nossa viagem aqui né não visando o
lançamento corinthians era aqui é desde
que eu seja um produtor internacional
que os marinheiros que usava os membros
do etá em ao sabor da corrente portanto
não havia aqui grande efeito sobre o
preço da locação e chegamos é o cursinho
com um bando de corvos marinhos que é
uma coisa que não lembro
no início do meu tempo mas não foi um
espetáculo é um espetáculo bonito
tínhamos aqui não tivemos tempo de
arrumar as nossas coisas e preparar o
primeiro jantar que seria na quinta do
noval união
primeiro veio para cá filha que é uma
quinta jornada da última quinta jonathan
e 40 fez cria um património imenso
durante a sua vida era uma visionária
ela é o festão aqui então e não combinam
tenha chegado a 152 você viu que o
comboio ia chegar ao sim
este ano já estamos lá aqui é a única
coisa que não existe nem no tempo da
notória é o candelabro que por acaso até
nem é muito bonito mas todo o resto era
o mobiliário e e aí usando está lá
jantar you jantado e os vários atentados
que durante esta viagem será protex
porque havia muito contato a mãe né é a
sentar com os com os descendentes santo
antônio com a mesma vontade anotada foi
quase todo destruído treinar no dia
seguinte
a próxima etapa é e aqui
contornamos é o rio pode ter passado
portanto eu faço com a virar para o
norte e pode servir para outra vez para
continuar duerheimer essa a impressão ao
mar e portanto
temos essa parte ea a barragem queriam
uma ilha que já o egito sonham e foi aí
que nós paramos para almoçar e aqui
andam foi prova no site e também pra
tomar banho foi o daquela semana esteve
mesmo nesse calor e uma é uma das minhas
netas que tem presidente por contar
queria ver o que o vasco na banheira
é esta o fato parece mesmo banheiro
o tempo também pra comer alguma coisa
entramos agora é entrarmos numa zona que
diz mais porque 10% de todas que eu
fazia nas quintas e tínhamos várias
pastas para casa naquela parte da região
era parte dos barcos do do rio é em que
nós temos que fazer as visitas às
quintas torre porque não havia acesso
por estrada com um problema está em todo
o lado é então ele nessa zona que é que
eu sair é o que eu e mais junto ao rio
que o rio no texto da imagem
vi nascer aqui a quinta trilhada por
cento que elas acumulam agora é do
sindicato dos cemitérios enfrenta o
francês fez não é tese numa outra outra
quinta potencia a a casa onde eu
trabalhava aqui daqui tudo sozinho e uma
quinta muito especial que era a quinta
do noval collio foi a primeira a quinta
onde eu ficar na minha primeira vindima
é e tenho tem essa carga tinha o sinal
será primária é e via a família se no
entanto seu projeto 0 em casa poder
aproveitá la
ou esse meu genro para tratar vocês vão
jantar e um além de ser que te faz a
gente tem 121 cozinhar e fez 11 sentar e
optará em a um serviço podia ver ou ela
quer o fim o que eu era responsável com
trabalhava com trabalhava na copa e
também em outras pato nós é mais pessoal
mas tive uma visita no final dessa
primeira menina é minha mulher z estava
à espera do nosso quarto filho e seu
quarto filho 35 anos pode sentou-se
exatamente em cima desse muro é um
perigo maior franquia na barriga
personagem é é depois aqui nosso fã do
fundo agradável esta noite só fomos
corridos com o ataque todas as formigas
- cedo logo de manhã
estamos a senhora declarando mais um
pequeno almoço ea mp da senhora da
fibeira outras quintas talvez mais
emblemática está sendo ligado também à
dona antônia
aqui todos garante a quitação é
conhecida como agora uma conquista em
todos houve e foi precisamente daqui do
sul viu que é em maio de 1961 zona pode
agora eu eo barão forrester passou o fim
de semana eo a régua e está em usar tel
o trágico acidente não deixando a galera
onde o variado as famosas a paz e nunca
mais foi visto no rio e eu quero eu só
posso dizer que estava muito vai e
antônia consegue chegar à margem da
nossa zona antônio dias filho ea filha a
função do la conseguiram pontuar
essa história que já está com pouco
tempo é que há sempre nestes e nestas
paragens alguém se interessa por
experimentar a nossa nossa entorno caso
uma americana que estava com um ano não
me ama jesus encontrou o caminho é e e
nessa noite fomos pra quem aqui tanto
parcelas que é da terra também outra
quinta é muito bonitinha aqui teve ativa
a notícia mais triste até desta desta
viagem é que uma coisa que não costuma
acontecer mas aconteceu avaliou a agenda
online e pra mim é um ponto é o ponto
chave nesta sexta feira passada o
pessoal vai todo mundo para tinha
naufragado eu tinha morrido mas enfim
tivemos que ir a volta para o barco é
pouco terra mas eu conheço minha sorriu
e sair é o que é assustador mesmo agora
é o rio é perfeitamente pacífico mas a
moça do curvas e entra na zona de
granito eu credito alto fica todo ator
tem assombrado e eu imagino os
marinheiros por van gaal vim pra vila
nova de gaia é a chegada do caixão
olha que era o maior o que acham que que
havia e e já pode sando
pela descrição do lançamento do veículo
estava sem haver a espuma e hoje não é
só ver mas fez um barulho da própria agu
no ano no caixão e aí os marinheiros
tiraram os sapatos e pois era seu
cliente quiser assinar e eu tenho que
passar mesmo é mesmo a falar era fim de
acidentes é o rio é estreita e passar um
passo pra pra passar o ano passado do
tua onde havia um quartel-general tanta
com deus onde eu ficava também é o tua e
é nessa casa do tua e vamos voltar a
cortar com um combóio clima de mirandela
a arrastar esta manhã é hoje quando
passar pelo tua e não quis olhar pra
próprio topo tem uma parede de cimento
que na outra vantagem é que você quiser
ser construída
daqui pra frente a uma série de quintas
é muito bonito e é e outros mal verdes
mas abaixo tem a quinta é que tudo vá lá
era uma das que depositava que agora é a
quinta conferência e do senhor também os
tímidos e vamos levar um fora
continuamos arrumados já em direção à
direção à opinião e à opinião está quase
a acabar o tempo mas ainda tenho alguma
mais duas etapas para fazer é e no
pinhão é uma zona de passagem e na parte
final do gran turismo que aconteceu hoje
no porto porque a partir de opinião já
não há já não há estradas 90 ontem que
irá dar a volta e é lá que as grandes
hotéis das quintas que recebem turistas
já montado ao turista na turismo de
habitação
só na amazônia também muito bonita é nós
observamos no dia seguinte por a
penúltima etapa é e é uma zona é o que
eu vivi muito nesses últimos seis anos
com o nome do preso não acaba e
trabalhar aqui é só gráfica que tem a
quinta só isso é a quinta é e do porto e
outra quinta que acabou por ser copas e
vender todo o sentimento que a equipe
ainda vou ver esta questão uma vez que
do vista é sempre esteve ligado ao
grande poeta não era do barão de cocais
eu tenho trazia o vinho lá mas vai ser
utilizada ou vai ser comprada pelos
filhos do dono foi assim que entramos
aqui do lindíssimo com os muros da
filoxera eu tenho da financeira é que
que é facto notável por trás desta desta
quinta é quitada nec tokin tocar nossa
senhora do carmo temos aqui na quinta do
crasto e vamos andando até uma paragem
obrigatória que é no pop na formosa é
que com a mulher do golfista número do
cpf
rui paulo é aqui no futebol essa
situação já em relação ao barco já
estava difícil mas tentaremos temperavam
várias vezes para ter água né é ainda
tempo para fazer tempo é que o nosso
desânimo e outro meu genro também
responsável por lan lan manutenção do
barco estava mesmo com adesivo é e foi
aqui que nós temos que parar na régua
não podemos ir até admira que ele mesmo
ponto final da nossa viagem e esses
eletrodos teremos mais um dia também um
pouco os planos mais à frente também não
era assim
não foi bonito mas é do brasil mas ainda
deu pra ilha agendar aqui tantas moças
que é o novo a nova aposta do scream
no dia seguinte também é e ainda a
passar na quinta dos frades que ama é a
quinta foram à casa naturalmente nas que
pertenceu instalaram
aquino na linha do douro pela a1 do
nosso primeiro rei dom afonso henriques
e que tiveram um papel muitíssimo
importante para o desenvolvimento da
viticultura é na região do douro
caso os animados podem ver fomos andando
já para a parte final da régua que é o
baú xto apanhar o barco na baía do do
bar que nós temos que ir sempre
acompanhadas com 11 é verdade um barco é
aqui que nos levava pronto lado da deco
lusa e que resulta na zona de elvas
antes chegado a a água na régua conforme
estava combinado
é eu tinha essa placa do para entregar o
instituto do vinho do porto é que era o
cassandra festa desta minha esta descida
foi desfeito o vice-presidente é coitado
estava tudo no porto com os grandes
festejos do porto andai é em entrevista
ao extra paga o meu testemunho é pela
passagem é na água estava a entregar de
texto mas ao mesmo tempo a passar no
barco e voltar e aprovar o barco quando
eu chegar e é eu tenho uma espécie de
colônia de ganhar muita miséria às
coisas materiais
o barco estava com a exaustão estava
todo remendado já tinha feito tudo
fizemos exatamente em todo caso é e teve
ajuda a várias pessoas para o caminho
para uma garagem onde eu pudesse
descansar e foram sorriso foram várias
pessoas ficaram neutros e peguem quanto
tempo com muito cuidado
entramos na garagem é e ao pousar o
parto de mil pessoas mas aqui o proesci
alguém estava que interessa dinheiro
depois desse tempo todo e desses traços
nós temos fazer e eu perguntei o que é
que eu ia tratar melhor eu tenho aqui um
bom final mas foi assim no final nós não
temos barco na garagem ocorreu à porta
da garagem e hoje 9 a minha viagem
terminou mas não voltarei a fazer outra
vez
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]